l' incendie s'est donc déclaré dans une
base militaire russe située en crimée
cette péninsule annexé en 2014 par
vladimir poutine et la russie le feu a
provoqué l'explosion d'un dépôt de
munitions appartenant à moscou cela se
passe dans le district de jang coy dans
le même temps l'ukraine assure avoir
endommagé une base du groupe wagner le
groupe para militaires russes dans l'est
du pays un pont près de mélie topol a
été détruit selon kiev les précisions de
mélina lui est elle est notre envoyé
spécial en ukraine
le gouverneur de l'oblast de dounia ce
qu'a annoncé hier que plus de 5500
personnes avaient évacué la région ça
veut dire qu'il en reste près d'un quart
près d'un quart des habitants qui sont
toujours là bas depuis que l'évacuation
obligatoire a commencé il ya près de
deux semaines on rappelle que volodymyr
zelensky a exhorté les habitants à
quitter la zone surtout à l approche de
l'hiver et alors que la destruction des
réseaux distribution de gaz risque de
priver les habitants de chauffage
notamment alors ce lundi les autorités
ukrainiennes ont annoncé que leurs
forces armées ont détruit une base du
groupe paramilitaire wagner à pop hasna
dans la région de louhans ce qu'un
toujours dans le donbass comment les
ukrainiens ont ils découvert les
coordonnées de ses bases bien tout
simplement parce qu'un journaliste russe
ses ventes et il ya quelques jours sur
les réseaux sociaux d'être avec les
paramilitaires de wagner sauf que sur
cette photo il y avait l'adresse de leur
camp ça c'est pour le dombass du côté du
sud et de renson plus précisément la
russie aurait transféré ses postes de
commandement de la rive droite du fleuve
ni pro à la rive gauche qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que ces forces
armées russes sont conscientes qu'en cas
d' escalade et bien elles ne pourront
pas être évacués à temps le gouverneur
adjoint de l'oblast de personnes a
assuré hier que les forces russes ne
pouvait même plus traverser à pied le
pont d'antonov cas donc encore moins
transporter des du matériel lourd et des
munitions alors à leurs troupes les deux
principaux ponts routiers donc celui
d'antonov cas et de nova caroff cas et
bien sont pilonnés réguler non par
l'ukraine depuis plusieurs semaines donc
des rites des bombardements à répétition
pour empêcher justement cet apport en
munitions et en matériel lourd qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que le
transfert de ces centres de commandement
d'une rive d'une rive à l'autre du
fleuve indique à minima une angoisse un
de ses troupes russes notamment parce
que il y aurait cette contre-offensive 1
qui approche des ukrainiens notamment
pour récupérer elle sonne
malheureusement pour eux le temps joue
un contre eux puisque l'automne approche
à grand pas qui va rendre la situation
beaucoup plus compliquée militairement
dès novembre peut-être même dès octobre